bom dia eu sou empresa silva só neste
tem 48 anos e é branding sol e boa
imagem da minha bandeira verde sorriso e
fôrmas alvo da suíça e entendo que uma
história de um amigo meu com previsão de
demanda em nova york sobre um livro de
um físico é e quando comecei a ler achei
que era a minha vida exatamente sobre a
entrada de um físico no mundo real
o tony hawk não escrevi o meu e-mail
parceria me encontrei vários sítios
dizia que um físico para entrar no mundo
real
eu ia precisar de um visto certo ser
troca eu não sei se tenho visto batalha
aqui em verona o manel maggi maggi mas
aquilo criou hoje tem um enorme prazer
em estar aqui convosco é partilhar um
caminho as confissões de um físico que
há 25 anos faz o papel higiênico
bom é e quase conseguia papel higiênico
é este produto que não tem esse grande
grande não é muito sexy é nossa gente
salva de palmas mexe mexe está a fazer
aqui uma pergunta alguém presidente com
papel higiênico não sei se alguém por
exemplo que vai tornar alguém tem uma
idéia quanto custa um dos rostos
telegénico muito vaiado evento que a
bóia volta dá a volta a volta dos dois
euros qualquer maneira ninguém fala
muito com isso pois acho que é sempre
caro porque é um produto porque é um
produto pouco pouco o quinto set e
partilhar convosco é essa história da
transformação de um produto papel
higiênico branco numa em produto que foi
uma tarde atípica que é o papel
higiénico preto enfim um lado o a
mudança para tapar um produto para um
produto diferente como é que aparece
como é que o preço do papel higiénico
preto e eu tinha eu tinha em 1100 eu
tinha um sonho sempre que podia ser
criança era físico campeão absoluto
perceber como é que o universo
funcionava e que podia fazer alguma
descoberta conteúdo isso para esse
conhecimento do universo e e e os meus
dois ou três minutos de fama 12 minutos
foram foram duas páginas foi uma
entrevista ao new york times
para falar sobre o papel higiénico preto
é verdade vezes na vida às vezes dá umas
voltas e aquilo que nós fra vão ser uma
coisa e é muito diferente voltas e
voltas e voltas que o mundo dá porque
por seu papel higiénico preto também foi
uma volta ao mundo eu tenho é algo que
faz com alguns dos meus colegas
é um projeto que não volta ao mundo que
andar por várias cidades do mundo
inteiro e visitar supermercados
hipermercados e vamos visitar sempre
transporte público as cidades como
cinema como o cantor única coisa que eu
queria era chegar à cidade e portel um
termo num autocarro no método que irão
se perguntar de ver a cidade a partir
dos sítios onde as pessoas compram e tem
uma coleção de fotografias muito grande
no mundo inteiro
continuo sempre fazer sobre o sombra e e
jos pelo case hipermercado sobre os atos
usados compra
acho que é extremamente este momento
importante devo dizer que nunca fui
preço
eu já fui expulso em todo o ato para
tirar fotografias num caos compra
só se me expulsar nunca fui preso mas
quase não vejo o estado emite é e não é
não é nenhuma dessas voltas ao mundo é é
combinei encontraram com nosso diretor
martin las vegas a vegas é uma cidade
fantástica uma deserta onde as pessoas
vão gastar dinheiro em contente eu não
há nada a priori é é de alguma forma um
paradigma de fixar e interessada em
estudar esse paradigma é porque tirei
essa decisão as velhas mudamos muita
coisa nova
do ponto de vista de marca com com essas
fotografias e com as quais trabalho mexe
as regras vão espetáculo cirque de
soleil o espetáculo já não lembro qual
era o nome tentado não saia sempre está
em seu auge e nenhuma regra do cirque du
soleil o espetáculo que tinha sobre o
corpo humano e só tinha os trapezistas
com os panos pretos em fio assim decidi
de espetáculo por que não vemos esse
papel higiénico preto
a idéia nasceu quase encerrar mas mexeu
no espetáculo circo só então as vendas
têm alguma coisa graça porque fui as
velhas vindo do da árvore não tinham
poder para fazer uma conferência sobre
inovação que é uma diferença também e
ele foi lá e papel higiénico preto e
bege
pode perguntar foi uma coincidência que
aparecer esta idéia e eu digo que não
tem uma razão alguma razão o primeiro e
todas têm a ver com imagens com imagens
porque o time ta duas ou três semanas
anos
mas um chute de uma fotografia com uma
campanha nossa tem 11 11 11 um casal
spears enfim que eu tinha muito a ver
com o papel e com rosto o genérico tem
aquelas imagens na cabeça na minha
memória é papel higiênico branco um
papel um rosto aparecia para ser tecido
e couro e quando vi a mesma coisa entre
o preto e os mesmos corpos o voluma
sucessão e primeiras imagens têm muita
importância daquilo que está na nossa
memória no seu corpo fora aqui
neurociências cobertas todas entrou
dentro das diferentes partes do cérebro
mas eu acho que há memória e é uma parte
da memória não racional que é muito
importante e que o terceiro e que deve
ser desenvolvida
bom é é apareceu a idéia é prosseguir em
torno do papel higiénico preto a gente
volte imensa as conversas assim que
falava no assunto era um assunto de
conversa de tal maneira o assunto
conversa que na altura conhecido é muito
simpaticamente convidado pelo presidente
jorge sampaio viagem está a a china e
num almoço em pequim
eu fui convidado muito muito simpático e
sempre vou estar na mesa dela estava com
umas oito pessoas da região e perguntou
qual era uma última inovação da prova e
foi o gene preto que não existia
independentes da província e pilotos
pois estava toda a gente fala que o gene
preto né mesa com o presidente da
república porque há aqui qualquer coisa
que qualquer coisa de estranho eu fiquei
muito vermelho caramba imagens a top não
sabia que iria enfim
por outro lado às vezes gosto muito
disso porque porque é um produto que não
existia e de um produto que não existia
por ser um produto que deixou de ser um
tabu e pessoas desistir
e nesse aspecto a gente gosta de quase
que inventamos um produto
se você é um produto que tem uma relação
com as pessoas que antes não tinha
apesar de alguém estava comprada pela
genética
[Música]
é esse produto teve que usar aqui aqui
aqui falar o menor o espaço mediático do
mundo inteiro o que tornou a marca nova
como esse mais contida e esse jogo nós
nunca imaginaríamos é o estado também
nos trouxe um desafio que é conseguir
transformar essa essa notoriedade
negócio esse é um desafio muito grande
que eu não vou não vou falar aqui é
também era muito difícil de justificar
por que fazemos um papel higiénico preto
e e nas conversas nova achava que a
minha maneira existe cara dizia ele foi
o clube nossa primeira campanha online
nota porque não estamos a falar falar
falar falar porque este é este
desenvolvimento esta lançamento deste
produto trouxe uma lição e uma
preocupação muito grande ea primeira
essa preocupação tem a ver com o fato
por acaso esta ideia foi minha mas se
não fosse minha muito possivelmente de
organização ao ter sido chumbada
isso é uma coisa que me preocupa da
criatividade das pessoas dentro das
organizações
poder é chegar e dar frutos e existir
porque confessa que mesmo eu muitas
vezes ter que justificar o assunto é e
ferramenta era preciso era preciso a
alguma força e algumas intimidades como
eu acho que consegue resolver isto você
ia criando uma cultura de inovação
dentro dentro da empresa é uma coisa que
nós temos forçado muito e que é uma
paixão pra mim é cultura é essa é que
permita ter
eu gosto de usar a palavra ter um
viveiro de idéias novas e um bocadinho
sobre isso que eu queria falar é um
grupo que nós temos que se chama berj eo
grupo deve retrair ser um trator de
ideias novas
dentro da nova não estou fora que de
investigação de um ponto de vista
técnico de engenharia ou mesmo do
marketing
são todos falar com o site nós mas com
um conceito novo conseguiram consegue
novo é uma coisa extremamente difícil
hoje em dia um conselho para ser novo
uma idéia por ser nova
tem que ser extremamente sofisticada
praticamente já tudo foi inventado o que
acho que é extremamente importante e e
estrear mais fácil e declinar idéias são
duas áreas notas
isso sim é um mundo imenso possibilidade
pelo menos eu acho que para nós tem que
ser humilde ao ponto dizer que carol
construir uma coisa nova mas conseguiu
inclinar um e deixando aqui um exemplo é
meu toque vir à minha frente é é ouvir a
fortunato e conseguir determinar no
papel e eletrônica e fazer um papel
eletrônico é é acho que é fantástico
estamos os dois domínios são diferentes
e que é possível ligá los
este grupo que eu tenho um grupo não só
esteve comigo não eu gosto de trabalhar
com físicos e tem alguns físicos nesse
nesse grupo
são pessoas que eu quero tenho duas
características em simultâneo e que só
um que são fáceis de ter pessoas
diferentes uma é uma dessas
características têm a ver com o fato
será em artistas crianças criativos que
destruam tudo não aceita nada disco tão
curiosos e e e a outra tv precisa um com
a engenharia como a matemática com
capacidades e precisão e tenta neste
grupo pessoas ter essas duas
características numa mesma pessoa que
todas tenham essas duas críticas é muito
difícil mas é importante quando estão
assim ar quando estamos assim acertamos
a sonhar quando partimos para a
implementação do do projeto então é como
a precisão que é matemática
estas pessoas têm um centro não sei como
é que chamaram costa dentro da nova que
o que deve interferir conta com toda a
organização e construiu o gosto muito da
palavra interferência nos meus tempos de
estudo
em física com a nossa língua mas como
explicar uma coisa de sempre qualquer
coisa explicou qualquer coisa e tem ali
um trunfo é o um trunfo franco presentes
gosto muito da palavra e diferença
daquilo que nós queremos e destruir eles
tomam café juntos em caso como o que o
manoel disse aqui também o final dos
jogos dentro da empresa
falei mais com as outras que estejam
almoço e fi e que tragam idéias gênero
em idéias não deixa de dizer que nossa
explica saúde e inovação
não foi fácil que esta criação este
velho se pode chamar assim próton site
fosse informal e na nossa certificação
está mesmo assim tem que ser informal
porque eu acho que muitas vezes as
pessoas não têm quando tem uma idéia
nova
não vão nos manter uma caixa que vai
escrever um e-mail espelharam triste
muito mais sobre o projeto enquanto a
pensar em fazer o gene preto é muito
importante que comuniquem ao ato e
quando comunicou ao ato outra pessoa às
vezes começam logo uma e outra e outra e
outra com essa faixa na bola dentro e
crias uma uma idéia uma idéia nova
o que faz com que muitas vezes o autor
de algumas idéias novas dentro dentro da
nova seja indeterminado não sabe quem
foi
foi um grupo foi um grupo assim tanta
bola um socorro a um socorro às criar em
duas ou três ou quatro horas e precisa
imediatamente essa é essa idéia nova
isso é o que eu quero que haja muito e
se esse viveiro fazer acontecer esse
viveiro e esse viveiro é de idéias e
também tanto das melhores desde ontem
tem convidado para falar sobre inovação
e muitas pressões que são feitas em
várias empresas que são as liturgias e
eu acho que isso é importante mas não é
suficiente é verdadeiramente viver essa
inovação criar essa cultura no dia a dia
e às vezes acho que é quase como criar
um desafio e de cada dia com por um post
no facebook com uma coisa nova e todos
os dias por ser parceira para ser uma
uma coisa nova na minha cabeça minha é
minha função deste grupo é um grupo que
não é também o meu crânio
é minha função é e eu muitas vezes subir
ou baixar a temperatura subir a
temperatura vai criar 1 401 cacau se
acha que estão demasiado focados em
qualquer coisa aí está um pouco antes ou
criar pouco ao contrário baixar a
temperatura e fiscalizar se afastou
completamente banidos com 50 mil idéias
que acontece com muito mais freqüência
essas pessoas têm que ter uma coisa
também muito importante que uma
resistência a derrota e são treinadas no
princípio deste grupo para ter uma
enorme resistência a derrota porquanto
acreditam verdadeiramente uma coisa que
o levem e até o fim de promover uma
autocensura dentro da organização
esse corte é a criatividade e deixe-me
dizer que muitos dias físicos nos
créditos é trabalhar com o uso das
coisas mais difíceis é conseguir
ultrapassar essa teimosia que às vezes
não é bom perceber essa imagem e é mais
temos dia qualquer mulher eu acho que um
grupo de suas fantásticas e e 15
privilégio muito grande em poder
trabalhar com essas pessoas que nós
pretendemos
queremos criar produtos novos podemos
criar
queremos criar uma mensagem de idéias
devemos criar diversidade reduzido
dentro e fora de dentro e fora do dentro
e fora da nova com pessoas muito fora
isso a versão é preciso nós seremos
capazes de prender a vontade do de ser
proprietário da marca das coisas mas
penso que tive há pouco tempo foi grande
em último anos criar foi perder um
carinha propriedade da marca no sentido
de começar a haver genta 2011 japão e na
coréia do sul começaram a apresentar
novas ideias e mudar o logotipo e
fazermos coisas diferentes que
antigamente seria perfeitamente
impossível de fazer mas eu acho que é
extremamente extremamente importante
dessa mudança de idéia
estou quase a terminar só pôde ver
algumas imagens que passei aqui que
podem parecer um cara estranha mas tem a
ver com um projeto que nós temos é um
projeto
artístico com vários artistas que são
residentes e não residentes nova e
questão é fotografar o a fazer o que
quer que seja dentro da sua banda em sua
área da sua área de um gosto sob uma
visão de frente dos locais nós temos
todos os dias no nosso cotidiano e é
muito interessante de ver alguém e uma
preta que nós vemos todos os dias e que
já não vemos é parceiro vai aparecer é
essa fotografia forma de forma diferente
e eu acho que é importante que às vezes
vemos tanta beleza tanta coisa positiva
e o mundo de maneira diferente onde o
benjamin zander contente possibilidade e
isso eu acho que mesmo muito importante
mesmo que seja um sítio nós ou nós ou
nós trabalhamos essa imagem só não é né
é juntar no centro do do rio a onda numa
na nossa fábrica mais mais mais antiga é
e eu acho que não tem alguma tem alguma
tem alguma beleza e para mim é muito
importante que as pessoas tenham prazer
na vida vida vale a pena ser vivida como
alguém diria que a única grande questão
filosófica é essa que nós pretendemos
temos produtos que sairão sexy e
engraçados divertidos e e eu gosto de
que sejam tão divertidos como como ipod
eff os nossos os nossos produtos
espero também que se divirtam com os
produtos que estão construindo as
amostras de muito obrigado pela
paciência que tiveram escutar aqui
[Aplausos]